foreign
[Music]
Wonderland of Promise pluck from
post-atomic flight the fruit of years of
prudent progress and determined
Reclamation and 15 million dwellers
worth of keen imagination from the heart
of West Virginia to the depths of the
pits
[Music]
no matter if you roam alone or spend
your time with friends you'll find a
home in Appalachia where the good times
never end there are relics to uncover
from a time before the war along with
loads of friendly folks to meet and
enemy's Galore our world is always
changing greater puzzles are overthrown
as we embark on Expeditions into
thrilling new unknowns yes from
Appalachian settlements to Nuka World on
tour you're never short on things to do
or places to explore think you've seen
it all hey well how about this pack your
bags for an escape of Epicurean Bliss
put your rad shield on and fix your hair
up pretty because we're headed for the
boardwalk of Atlantic City
so there you have it now you know
there's a million ways to make the
Wasteland your waste home and when you
hear Adventure calling when you're
looking for some kicks answer the call
answer
the call of all 76
play it now with Xbox game pass